si vous ne connaissez pas moi mais déni
à chaque fois c'est vrai qu'ici tu meurs
très connu moi je l'adoré très drôle
spécialisée dans le foot très très très
très drôle vraiment mais vraiment très
drôle et subjective sa série maintenant
j'ai pas pour moi tu es drôle ont tracé
c'est vrai que c'était là daniel tu sais
que tu le connais pas mais avec jean le
poulain
on a une vidéo de toi sur un plateau tu
commenter un match tu t'es un peu
emballé à cause de l'om qui était pas au
top regard des attentes pas se faire
avoir à la fin de courbe élargie qui
suit son joueur c'était ringard
[Musique]
et puis
je
mais possible c est ce qu en dernier
l'om diadhiou titre l'om si hadj la
ligue des champions l'a finement mère je
suis deg la vie de ma mère je suis dit
que c'est incroyable
casse des téléphones alors voilà c'est
son truc aussi et c'est vrai que ta ta
ta ta plus de télé chez toi + t d
malheureusement la femme donc ne peut
pas nous regarder à la radio je crois
d'accord elle est partie j'ai fait
partie de la famille adacore donc
travers donc il ya toujours une tv dans
la famille pour qu'il
se relève toujours une ville a perdu sur
cette vidéo et à monter le curseur tu as
utilisé un engin improbable pour casser
une telle y regarder
voilà les amis pour ceux qui connaissent
et
qui prouvent des poids légers
alors qu'il ya des gens qui sont choqués
sur est proposé mais c'est vrai que là
ils disent regarde daniel n'allait pas
bien
c'est une brève en accord avec une
marque ou si
je refuse de faire ça parce que si je
casse ma télé au moment où la casse la
marque à la part et ça gâche un peu le
truc et en plus si aucune marque ma
démarche et faut pas se mentir donc non
j'ai pas sponsoring je les achète avec
les propres moyens et moi j'ai toujours
dit les télés c'est comme les
prostituées personne ne les paye en fait
c'est moi c'est moi qui
apprécie tape à certains l'ont reconnu
ah oui d'accord non et on directeur
[Rires]
après fait ce qu'il veut
la loi je sais que ça
vient mais pas très clair toi
je préfère te dire
mais je ne trouve pas très clair voilà
jardine toi qui aimes le foot banon mais
il est génial il est très drôle il est
très sympathique les mômes le regard de
connaissent toutes ces vidéos parker le
regarde tout le temps bouquet moi je
trouve qu'il met une très très très
bonne ambiance et c'est une manière de
parler de foot différemment et moi et
j'aime beaucoup moins mais c'est un
super joueur de poker alors il ya une
question oui mais s'il ya des fans qui
limite à la maison c'est de la non
justement mais ouais c'est vraiment lui
ils peuvent pas se permettre donc
justement ce que je fais moi ça que
comme les rollers kick ass et les chats
noirs
est une vidéo le prix d'une télécentres
300-400 euros un rappeur quand il sort
un clip ses vingt trente mille quarante
mille euros ouais au final c'est un
budget de 300 à certains qui émet des
trente mille euros danger boulimie des
hausses étaient partis chercher une télé
c'est pour les gens qui ont vu la casse
et chez eux
bien sûr cette thérapie alors il ya une
troisième vidéo alors là tu avais pas de
télé à dispo à utiliser autre chose
regarder la télé chez
germain c'est le pas il s'en sort bien
mais six les deux lutins mieux mais
cynique
c
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est le budget du coup ça m'a fait un
scooter des mers
avait répété avant ça en fait ça qui est
faux dans mes vidéos c'est que j'ai le
droit à une prise en main c'est ça c'est
une télé je peux pas à casser raté ma
vie dans la roue construire la roque à
selongey le scooter aussi droit à
l'erreur c'est ça exactement mais c est
alors enfin tour cyril avec celui avec
plaisir j'arrive par contre j'espère et
je vais peut-être plutôt aller à
marseille qu'à mykonos
peut-être très potes sécurité très
proche de karim benzema c'est le show
l'adorent un karim aussi il ya eu enfin
là il a vécu il ya un an qui a beaucoup
pesé tu as demandé de parler de gillon
d'olivier giroud un regard
est ce que tu penses que giroud
à ce qu il a le potentiel pour titulaire
à ta place ça va être vite fait les mecs
ne confonds pas la f1 on ne confond pas
la f1 et le karting et je suis gentil
voilà maintenant next je parle même plus
c'est très cool cat et moi je sais que
tout est fin
prêt oui non mais c'est pour ça que
c'est super parce que il ya tellement de
gens qui parlent de foot là non mais là
ça sort du langage codé du langage
codifié qu'on a d'habitude et si c'était
pas vous il n'aurait jamais dit ça
exactement pour ça que c'est super et là
enfin il est sincère il se lâche alors
que d'habitude souvent c'est du langage
des séries et d'autres vidéos que vous
démontrez va faire plaisir à certaines
personnes autour de cette table que je
ne nommerai pas qu'est-ce que mathieu
regarder on verra juste après six mois
mais n'a qu'une parole regard merde
bonjour à tous les amis pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas ou g et les crocodiles
qui met du lacoste les amis je suis
obligé de réagir ou là arrêtez de parler
de neymar au pg ou là j'en ai marre
bande de sales mito arrêté vous et de
rumeurs ou alive viendra pas au pg
neymar la vie de ma mère y viendra pas
cinéma riom pg je sus tout laisse book
de paname la vie de ma mère j'avais déjà
dit une fois mais c'est risqué là je
suis sérieux vous êtes sérieux ou cause
est pété les plombs
[Applaudissements]
était pas mal à disposition
originaire depuis deux générations
de plaisir il ya un début à tout non
mais c'est vrai j'avais fait cette
promesse mais déjà ils ont vu le
contexte aujourd'hui c'est banal mais si
elle bat p mais à l'époque en 2010 et
qu'on disait neymar vient au pg c'était
le j'y croyais vraiment pas ce que tu es
prêt à couper impossible qui viennent
j'avais fait le site connaît maintenant
on sait que pourrait prendre ce
que je ferai pas le même pas mis
aujourd'hui j'étais vraiment ne vous
croyez vraiment pas du tout bref on a
perdu quoi
j'avais dit que j'avais su c'est tout
est ce beauf de paname aujourd'hui c'est
tout laisse book de paname qu'ils me
sucent donc on a inversé un peu là
pourquoi t'es pas clair toi